and I'm going to give us some
definitions of product marketing and
product management so because this is
not an overview of what the positions
are but really just talking about your
careers and how to get to the top in
product marketing and product management
so to begin with I'm going to start with
sir the continuum from product launch
through to from product concept through
to product launch I'm going to start
with strategy and there is a strategic
part of it I'm not going to assign that
to product marketing or product
management but somebody's going to come
up with the idea it might be in a
business plan or a marketing
requirements document but there it
starts with the strategy the next part
continues to inbound product management
and this is everything from gathering
the customer requirements putting them
into a product requirements document
might be known as a PR D it might
include functional specs very detailed
it includes working with engineers it
includes documentation testing QA beta
customers up to ultimately launch there
might be some other activities because
product managers are always a very busy
person
the next part on the continuum is really
the outbound product marketing you
notice I said inbound product management
outbound product marketing on the
outbound side we talked about all of the
messaging and positioning and on the
outbound side we're talking about how
you deliver the messages to your
customer maybe it's a segmentation and
how you target them it's all of the
marketing collateral the sales training
it might include analyst briefings it's
all the powerpoints web content seminars
trade shows all of the content behind
the product and how you reach your
audience with that content and so I just
wanted to kind of lay that terminology
definition there's a couple things I
didn't note and that is pricing you know
that might be determined by sales so I'm
not putting it in product marketing or
product management and I kept strategy
out also because you could define it in
other
places and I just want to just throw out
those definitions and I know our
panelists might add to them but we'll
hear more from them about the
backgrounds the skill sets and I thought
this would lay some framework for us to
discuss it so at this point I'd like to
turn it over to Deborah Hanken who is
going to be our moderator for this
evening
Deborah hello it's a pleasure to have
you all here with us tonight we're going
to run the panel in a little bit of a
different way in order to add some
variety
not every panelist is going to answer
each question but panelists if there's
something you want to add that has not
been yes press your magic button and I
will call on you and you can then get in
whatever you need to I also understand
from the panelists that some of them
don't believe this definition of product
management and marketing is quite
scientific so I'm sure we'll be hearing
some from some of you what I'd like to
do right now is to ask each member of
the panel to give a brief background of
where they've been and how they have
gotten to where they are today so we'll
start with which over at the end thanks
in brief as possible I were
one now spent a couple of years at HP
writing code in the early 80s that was
about the time that electricity was
invented came back here this is a school
to do an MBA and have been doing more or
less you know product management for
technology products since about 87 10
years of that with big companies tandem
Sybase the next 10 years with startups
so for startups through which you've
never heard of the one called I pass did
go public in 2003 and that included 2
years of consulting which is liberally
defined as I didn't have a startup to
work for for 2 years and so I was
consultant it started a newsletter that
somebody may have seen on product
management and startups great my name is
Rita yo kita and I've been in the
software industry for about 20 20 odd
years variety of different roles
actually my experience has been probably
more field based to begin with I worked
an Donna Bradstreet software long time
ago
that was pretty RP days actually and
spent at that time there doing
professional services engagement
management and then went on to work for
PeopleSoft
for nine years mainly in the field doing
customer service work care management
professional services business
development and then finally landed as
head of financial product strategy and
certainly I have a different point of
view coming from a large company in
terms of what large companies do in
terms of how they define product
management and product strategy I'm now
with a startup company and it's very
different there so I can tell you about
the transition from going from large to
small but they're they define products
product strategy our products really as
products drug strategy product
management and product marketing and I'm
very happy that product marketing is
part of that got to that threesome
great thank you hi my name is Tiffany
Riley
I got sucked into the vortex that is the
Silicon Valley about 12 years ago
actually my background was more on the
sciences in biology and thought well
I'll go do something different for a
while so I think the main thing there is
that no matter where you came from
with the right set of skills that we'll
talk about tonight you can actually go
pretty far in the valley here I've been
very fortunate to have experiences at a
pretty broad set of companies I started
out my career at Sybase and really got a
sense of big company marketing at a very
unique time when it was trying to
overcome a set of perceptions in the
market started out in the marketing and
customer programs side of thing which
really fostered my passion for customers
their needs and what can we do to help
solve customer needs a transition to a
company called Scopus which was in the
very early days of the crm craze one of
the companies who actually got that
market going and so to be a part of
making a market was a fantastic
experience both from a product
standpoint as well as a marketing
standpoint and then transition to a
small company called glue pumpkin which
is in the the call center space so got
to experience the world of funky names
amongst a very rigid experience and
really got the experience there around
making a brand for someone and really
leveraging and understanding the world
of creativity in software I think that
the software industry again two
arguments with my friends in the
consumer world about where you can be
more creative consumer or b2b and I
actually think there's a lot more
creativity to be had in the b2b world
so my background through most of those
was in the product marketing and product
management and at blue pumpkin took over
the role of all of marketing at blue
pumpkin which was quite a jump to make
to go from focusing on the product to
all of the different aspects and just
fell in love with not only focusing on
the product but also being able to look
at how you bring that to market and have
taken that experience with me and I'm VP
of Marketing now at
a company called next steps my name is
David Strauss like rich I started with
HP some 20 many years ago please in
Cupertino thank you destroyed exactly
and like which started from an
engineering point of view you know I had
a funky career path I started with a
double major in business and began
engineering from there we can talk about
how you get from one to the other
I think the key lesson that started then
and has been I guess following me ever
since is that the path has never been
what I expected it to be in the
engineering world there was a very
bright general manager who decided that
I wasn't as good of an engineer as I
probably wasn't some other role and
guided me very gingerly towards
marketing and taking a product view of
the world and customer view of the world
did 10 years at HP is a very large
company didn't like the size of the
company really had more of an
entrepreneurial spirit went to my first
startup in the early 90s have done
multiple since then the company called
open vision technologies which we sold
to Veritas did a little company Atlanta
the some VCS kind of said you want to
come to Atlanta for a couple years my
wife and I said what the heck sold that
went to Indus started a company called
on-demand wish I kept the the website
for that one that we sold to accordion
software in early 2000 2002 and now in a
company called corticon and other
early-stage companies in the business
rule to manage in the States
for the whole panel what part of the
most important skills that an executive
in product marketing and management
needs whilst I would date this time so
it's interesting I think the job
description of product marketing and
product management leads most of us in
the wrong direction and I've seen too
many people focus on product as the
center of the job so I think the most
important skills is customer I think
there are you know in this role there
are two core constituencies the people
who will eventually buy the product and
the people who sell the product to the
people who buy the product and those are
my customers
and every time that I seen a product
marketing our management person to worry
about the product before the customer I
think they fail
I would agree with that and there's
definitely a theme throughout as I was
going through this that the customer
know your market is absolutely important
no matter whether you're an individual
contributor product marketing management
person or at the executive level and I
think a key part of that especially in
today's information age is having a
process for yourself to digest the
tremendous amount of information that's
going to come to you about your market
about your customers what's going on in
the sales organization what's going on
in the product organization and you
absolutely have to be able to maintain a
discipline or you will go nuts trying to
digest all of the information and
related to that from an executive
perspective is having a team underneath
you that you've hired you've hired well
and that you can keep them organized and
prioritized I think one of the toughest
things about the job is that you sit in
the middle of so many different pieces
of the company everybody wants a piece
of your time and so a big part of the
skills is being able to balance and
manage the trade-offs between all the
different groups and unless you really
have a handle on what the company's main
objectives are and what are the things
that your team needs to do to line up to
that you'll never be able to have good
discussions and you'll never make
anybody whether it's your customers
salespeople are engineering happy
it's always hard being the third one
down isn't it I think one of the most
important skills not only from an
executive or just product managed
product product management or product
marketing it's the skill of listening is
one of the most important skills that
you can learn and you really have to
start doing it very early in your career
because listening isn't just hearing
it's in fact understanding understanding
what the person is trying to tell you
and really delving into it so it's not a
skill that is particularly related to to
to product marketing or product
management but it is a skill that I
think is one of the most important ones
that will make you successful or not
successful and to add to Tiffany's
comments I think that whole area of
there's so much information out there
that you have to be able to give
yourself time to digest and really
really know what the market is out there
you can't go on just a sliver of
information you have to understand the
entire entire piece of information that
you have and then make the right
decisions so part of that
decision-making process is around
looking for the small things that are
very very creative in that extensive
research that you end up doing and some
of those small things can be really huge
things and so I think learning when to
do that is really important and I also
agree with Tiffany on the organizational
aspects hiring the right people getting
the right people in the right seats on
the right bus if anybody's read good to
great is really important because
otherwise you won't be able to do the
bigger job that you need to do great of
course I'll be with everybody else let
me come back to something that David
said first in the sort of line product
manager job but you wanted to exact seen
over and over again is you turn out to
need to be bilingual which means you can
speak customer and you can speak
engineer and by the way the customers
don't really care how the insights the
product work and the engineers don't
really understand what customers do and
so there's this constant need to go back
and forth these simultaneous translator
and take things
customers say and put them in terms and
engineers can implement and then explain
why the thing that came out the other
end is what customers want and and if
one shouldn't confuse that with some
document like an MRT because you know
half the people on each side didn't read
it anyway so there's there's that that
sense of participating on both sides I
think as you move up the organization
the key thing I've seen as an executive
in the product role is that rather than
having to worry about individual
products what you're really doing is
you're watching for organizational
breakages right so you've seen the movie
over and over again where support
doesn't talk to engineering and
engineering something and support isn't
trained right is that a product problem
well it is until you fix it and so if as
the product executive you know if you're
responsible for customers having a great
experience what you're doing is you're
watching the shape of the organization
and all the motivators across all the
different groups trying to get all the
children to play nicely and share the
crayons because if the group's don't
work well and none of the work for you
what comes out the other end is not good
and so so you end up owning the process
in the big sense even if you're not
allowed to tell anybody that because of
course everybody on their own piece the
the product management person or the
product exec has to Shepherd through the
system whatever it turns out to be so
the things that come out the end are
good
so all you've been very successful and
we look at as there are two two sides of
the skill one is the product management
and marketing side and the other is the
leadership the ability to manage a team
so I'm going to ask Tiffani and Dave to
talk about which of these many product
management and marketing skills have
been most useful as they've moved up and
then rich and Rita about what leadership
and management skills have been most
useful to you
Tiffani mr. thing called dovetail off of
what Rita said is one of the key things
in terms of of listening and the the
role of both product marketing and
product management is to translate what
the customers or the market wants into a
product or into a set of messages that
will go to the market and you need to be
able to listen and understand what your
current customers want and also what the
market at large is looking for and not
just to understand it at a feature level
but to really understand what their
needs are what their success factors are
as people as an organization what
motivates the people that you're going
to be selling your products to and at
the end of the day you have to be the
market experts in your company and that
just adds an extraordinary amount of
credibility as you go to talk to the
engineering organization if they trust
that you know the customers and that
you're going to lead them into the right
direction they will follow you the sales
organization no matter what the last
three deals were again if they believe
that you represent the market and you're
going to show them the paths of the
success they will follow you and the
same holds true from the executive and
just a company perspective and it's that
credibility that really allows you to
rally the troops or
that on a more tactical perspective
project management is just an absolutely
critical skill because you touch so many
different departments in the company you
have to be able to rally the troops not
only with your credibility and your
energy but also with a sense of
organization so that the little things
that at the end of the day can turn into
the big things don't fall through the
cracks so again I think there's a lot of
agreement amongst the panel and I agree
with everything that Tiffany said a
couple additional items you have to be
outbound so if you want to sit at your
desk if you don't want to get on the
airplane if you don't want to spend time
with these people who are the customers
um I think you can become a decent to
mediocre product marketing and
management person and if you want to
become really really good you have to be
tied to the customer you'd have to be
really comfortable and like getting out
there having those interactions I would
tie to that that you have to be come
sales focused in your mind I mean what's
the objective of a product manager it's
to create a successful product that
drives a lot of revenue and being a
salesperson is not an easy job and you
know the there's a ton of information
and there's features and functions and
presentations and I mean sales people
don't necessarily consume all this
information that all these wonderful
marketing organizations have created and
if they don't gain with Tiffany
suggested which is confidence in you
then they will not have confidence in
what you produce and then they're going
to start second-guessing and producing
it on slide decks and taking different
cuts of the world and then you end up
with what I've seen in a lot of
organizations sales and marketing don't
mix just like product management and
engineering don't mix a lot of companies
because they don't find this common
ground so again without bound if you're
not prepared to spend again depends on
the company if you're an ASP model maybe
a little bit different if but if you're
not prepared to spend time with the
field out there fighting the battles and
helping them win the bales and learning
with them you probably won't get that
adoption of the field to you and
therefore to your or product and
ultimately if your work product isn't
adopted it doesn't matter how smart you
are I would say that you have to take a
solution focus not a product focus
because in the end people don't buy a
product they buy a solution to a problem
and so if there aren't the other things
around and I've seen too many
organizations where the product manager
worries about the feature functions of
engineering produces it doesn't worry
whether there's training or whether
there's a support structure or all the
other things that's necessary to make
the product work you can produce a
pretty ineffective product in in in the
market and then the other thing that I
would say is you have to kind of be
bipolar to be a good product marketing
and management person on one side you
have to have the optimism and enthusiasm
and belief in your product I mean you
have to be an evangelist you have to
know and be able to reflect that
positive nature at the same time when I
say people do that without the other
side of the skill
which is kind of being brutally honest
or very very critical then you end up
starting to believe your own marketing
and there's nothing worse because our
job is to continually test because if it
was that formulaic if we knew how to
analytically assess exactly the right
product in the right way there'd be a
lot more successful companies out there
right a lot of this is just judgment and
so if you're not out there saying okay
we said this you know like is it right
our people believing it you know can can
we really get adoption on this vector if
you're not being more brutal about what
you're saying in the privacy of your
office with your peers then you know you
will probably go a little bit off-track
rich ruler let's talk about leadership
and management skills um sure again
touching on a couple things we said
before I think at the management level
at the executive level I think it's
important to foster the sort of shared
belief that getting to the right answer
is more important than whose answer it
is that you know is so you could call
that the mediator or the moderator role
those of us who did the GSB thing would
say it's a little taste of touchy-feely
but you know if you're the the point of
intersection if you're the glue that
holds the organization together what's
really important is it everybody
believes they're the reason why
something successful and so there's a
lot of pulling people together to do the
things that they were supposed to anyway
but just sort of haven't gotten around
to doing and it seems like the the
product management spot is the one where
you see all the holes and we try to fill
them and try to give them back to the
people who who owned them and in order
to do that you've got it both be and be
perceived as somebody who's not around
ego gratification or you know grinding
their own axe it's about what's right
for everybody I mean [ __ ] without it
becoming a committee decision oh yeah so
you already know the right answer you
just got to get everybody there but you
can't let them know
the right answer is completely obvious
to everybody who doesn't work at that
company but
but I didn't tell you that that's
standing up on the table and you know
beating your chest and saying I'm right
and I'm smarter is well it's a really
long way from that to the next promotion
I guess when I look at the leadership
management skills that you know that
that were important to me as I as I
moved up it was really recognizing that
not everything I didn't have to do
everything and so it's easy when you're
a product manager to think that you've
got the weight of the world on your
shoulders but as you grow up as you go
up through the chain and start to have
people that work for you
the most important thing that you can
learn is to let go and the most
important thing to do is to foster that
in fact that those people that work for
you are the ones that are probably going
to have the details that you use to
think and hold closely to your heart and
until you can let go of some of those
details you can't start doing the things
that you really need to do from a
management point of view and if there
was one particular thing that I had to
learn and learn over and over again is
to let go of those details that I so
loved and especially when you're in the
software industry and you get so
enamored of sitting down and talking
about the best way to do XYZ whatever it
is I think the most important thing is
to learn to let go and then to trust the
people that you've hired for the jobs
and to bring them along because they
will make you successful if you've hired
the right people so to me that was one
of the most important things that I
certainly learned along the way
and then the other thing that I learned
is that as a as a person that in fact
has a certain level of experience
there's as Tiffany said there's a
certain amount of credibility that you
gain in an organization and once you've
gained that credibility what you have to
be really careful of is not to lose it
and to continue to foster that
credibility because that will make you
successful that will make you successful
not only in terms of your peers but the
people that you report to so I think
those are the two if I look at
leadership management skills that I've
learned along the way that have been
very important to me
so you talked about how you have to have
a team so this leads into our next
question which is what advice do you
give your team to be successful you've
all been successful how do you make your
team successful and what Tiffany and
rich answer that one this is what am I
my favorite one sure people are rolling
over in their graves right now I think
we beat this one to death and I will
beat it again because it's fun
number one is absolutely know your
market and knew your customers and not
from a feature function perspective but
to live and breathe the world of so what
who cares and why and if you work with a
good sales person they will come back at
you constantly with those questions and
so if you can live and breathe those as
you go out and talk to the market and
talk to the customers and think about
why you want to build certain product
and why you want to market product in
certain ways that will help make you
extremely successful and is a part of
that using examples I think it's very
easy in our jobs to live at a 10,000
foot level and when you're out there
talking to a customer or talking with a
salesperson or an analyst one of the
most powerful things that you can use
our examples of things that you've
learned either what customers are doing
with your products the business problems
that they have to get those head nodding
heads nodding in the audience that you
understand the customers world no matter
who you're talking to so that they feel
that credibility and they're going to be
more apt to buy your products from you
and that kind of relates to the next
thing which is I always encourage my
people to think from the other side of
the table as you're putting pricing
together think about what a rep is going
to want to know and have to explain to
the customer about why you've chosen to
package or price things in a certain way
is your negotiating features with
engineering think about from their
perspective that there
to figure out how do we build all of
these different pieces and so as you
explain to them what the customer
requirements are come at it from that
angle is you're dealing with executives
they're working at with way too much
information they need to know things
very succinctly very precisely and at
just the right level and so as you work
with all those different groups think
about it from their perspective and
leverage all of the great ideas rich
messiness I just think that is one of
the most important things don't feel
that you have to have all the answers
yourself there are really smart people
around you and some of the best ideas
come from the most bizarre places in the
organization and listen to those I think
it's easy for us to put engineers in a
box and I've been very fortunate to work
with engineers who have actually had
some of the best marketing ideas that
are out there because they're not
inhibited by the same things that were
inhibited of what we can and can't do
and I think that's a very powerful thing
to take advantage of and the last thing
is you can't as a product manager of
product marketer take things on a
one-off basis sales has a request you
know so what a customer wants a certain
feature you have to constantly take
things into context and I had a long
conversation about this with somebody
earlier that if a customer comes to you
with a feature request go back to them
with the other 15 things that they've
asked you for and talk to them about how
important this one thing is relative to
everything else sales person comes to
you and they want that new - eat on
whatever it is here's the other 20
things that you've asked me for where
does this fall in the relative set of
priorities it just it makes the
relationship go much better it shows
that you're listening and also make sure
that what you deliver at the end of the
day are the most important things to
your company into your customers as you
can see I'm very passionate
Greg thanks just a couple of thoughts
one is I think it's natural for somebody
who's just starting out particularly on
the product management side to believe
that completing a document is an
important step in life and that
everything that went into that MRD was
work but gosh you know I finished it I
published a emailed it to everybody we
printed it now let's go have a drink
right and I think that sort of misses
the the ebb and flow of well it's really
an ongoing negotiation right because
everything you put in there you're not
going to get it all and next week you're
going to be back trying to figure out
which of the 20 things you're going to
have to drop anyway so if you don't get
as emotionally invested in little point
pieces and you stay focused on the
overall trend toward product I think
that's that's healthy um the other thing
that that that my folks have done a few
times and forgive me for second up I'm a
parent and for those of us in the
audience who are parents any analogy
with how for instance sales people think
completely accidental but you know on
those one-off things we always we always
try to play the game to say you know
your kid wants dessert before a dinner
tonight but she promises that tomorrow
night she'll eat dinner in the right
order right anybody who has a kid knows
that you're either in or you're out of
it the special discount we really only
want one since the end of quarter and
it's a special deal right okay so we're
going to go into room
Dornan and the proud folks are going to
talk about what happens next week when
we say yes to this sales rep in there
with these two promises he's never going
to tell anybody else that he got this
special discount for his customer okay
what are the implications let's play the
game forward a few steps you know what
happens if you know we D well all of
engineering to do this one feature for
this one customer that we're actually
not sure we're going to close okay you
know what are the implications two steps
down four steps down because that's how
the the product team gets smart about
explaining why they're making choices
and they get more confident because the
next time they're in a tough situation
they're going to have some visceral
basis for how good decisions get made
because we've all sat around in the
privacy of their own little conference
room to talk about how bad decisions get
made and what they look like it's great
let's change a little bit of track we're
going to talk about mentors a little bit
what we'd like to know and I'll ask Rita
and David s is how do you have mentors
or a role model when did you get one I'm
going to add the question how did you
get one how did you get somebody to
agree to be your mentor or your role
model Rita go ahead I guess a mentor
that I that I think I relied mostly on
is I had a mentor in the sales
organization that taught me everything
that I really needed to know from a
sales methodology point of view and also
taught me a lot about you know
positioning and product positioning and
that person was very instrumental in my
understanding of how product marketing
fits within the sales organization how
important it is to them to give them the
right set of tools that they need to go
out and market the products that that I
so love to build at the time so that
sales person was one of the best sales
persons I've ever seen in my whole life
I mean sell gia a general ledger product
for nine million dollars to
company is like it's pretty big and
she's just awesome she taught me
everything that I know both from a
presence and credibility point of view
and just how important it is to have the
right the right product positioning the
right product the right sales tools so
that these guys can go out and sell and
make a lot of money so that was early in
my life that was I was in and actually I
wasn't even a product marketing role at
the time I was in a business development
role and she taught me a lot about what
I needed to know going forward how did
you find her how did you make that
connect she was in she was in the field
organization that I was working at at
the time in PeopleSoft and you know they
were she's just a crackerjack I mean she
just I just really glommed onto her
she'd I just followed her everywhere for
a while and learned everything that I
needed to tell from that sales point of
view and that helped me tremendously
okay Dave what about you did you have
somebody as well so the answer is yes
and many and you know this is to you
know kind of an interesting point at
Tiffany made which is you know you get
some great ideas from some areas he
wouldn't expected you know I had a early
mentor when I was at HP use a general
manager in the division and the thing
that he told me was that I should learn
from others mistakes he said and I have
a friend who you know with very
successful his career and he says you
know what I can't learn if I don't make
the mistake myself right I have to go in
there and try it and against the wall
and you know three board later he
realizes gosh board numbers don't
actually want the truth there's a shock
so you know Doug really taught me that
everyone around you is a learning
experience and I had mentors at many
different levels I've had there was a
guy who was kind of a rising star at HP
and I knew him when I was there and we
maintained a relationship there was I
would say more personal and that he
became an investor in my startup and sat
on the board you know and some of these
relationships have lasted years some of
these relationships have lasted months
but I think if you have some value to
add to somebody right if there's a
reason for them to spend time with you
in terms of their world and you're
willing to listen to them which i think
is key and we've talked about that as
product marketing people as product
management people right you have to
listen I think there's just a tremendous
amount of mentorship that you can get
from places you can't even imagine and
for people who don't even know that
they're mentoring you so you really have
to stay open and and look for that value
I think in a very very small way some of
you may be here because you're looking
for a little bit of that just in you
know one hours worth of discussion from
the four of us
what about Tiffany or rich would you
like to comment if you had role models
what have you learned uh let's see I'd
say for the first half of my career I
was oblivious enough to the whole
question and I probably did and missed
out I missed out on all the
opportunities because I was being really
smart and nobody else does this morning
I was and later on I think you know a
good shovel full of humility was really
necessary to get to listen to smart
people a guy named Debbie Thompson I
work for and I pass real really smart
wonderful guy you know and what what he
told me and then he taught me was
executives get paid to make decisions
and to keep organizations running and
everything else is busy work and so if
you spent your whole day you know
sitting with the engineers figuring out
how to do something more elegantly
that's fine but maybe didn't earn your
money today you know and that's putting
it harshly but you know just 20 right
but you actually have to pay attention
because people are out there waiting and
willing to help you if you'll just give
them the time to let them help you and I
think too looking a lot of the mentors
that I've had have actually some of them
have been in the marketing area but a
lot of them have been in other areas and
so I would definitely encourage you to
look for leadership in areas where you
don't necessarily have a full set of
skills and is rich setting people are
willing to help they love to share the
knowledge that they have and so don't
assume that just because you're in a
different department that somebody
doesn't necessarily want to help you and
that's been incredibly powerful
throughout my career so rich you
mentioned one mistake
was thinking you were too smart that
leads us to our next question
Tiffany in which what mistakes are most
common for product marketer and
management people to make I'll take
whatever you letter studied take
whatever she forgot for sure I felt like
answering this question to some degree
was the laundry list of things I've done
wrong at some point or another I think a
couple of things it's a really really
challenging role and I think that's one
of the things that makes it such a fun
challenge for really smart people and
why you see such a great group of people
who are in the product marketing product
management profession one of the things
that I see a lot and I still struggle
with this on a day to day basis is it's
really easy to get sucked into the
Tasmanian Devil that is sales and while
we've talked a lot here about you need
to be sales focused you need to walk in
the same set of shoes you can't let them
rule and drive your life the product
marketing product management function
can be a wonderful grounding function or
a traffic up for the company and I think
if you get too caught up in one
departments perspective particularly
sales it will drive it crazy and B it
will lead you to make some decisions for
your company for your in for your
solutions that may not be the best
solutions the flip side of that however
is that too often I see product managers
or product marketers who are not
aggressive enough I think it's really
easy to get caught up into the world of
I can't or I don't have time instead of
thinking how can I even if it's a matter
of making trade-offs or doing things
differently or doing things 80 percent
instead of a hundred percent with things
come to your table the first reaction
shouldn't be to freak out and oh my god
I can't do that I already
other things else that I need to get
done either on a sales or on on a
product a perspective and so think about
how you can be aggressive whether it's
from a vision standpoint whether it's
from a workload standpoint or pushing
the organization around you to help you
get done what you need is a part of that
the last thing that I'll touch on is
that being in product marketing and
product management it's incredibly
important role that is getting a lot of
attention in companies companies are
investing a tremendous amount in that
organization and function because they
recognize how important it is just
because you have that title on your
business card does not get you the
get-out-of-jail-free card in terms of a
lot of things that we've talked about
already the credibility engineering
isn't just going to tell you to do
things because you wrote a really nice
MRD with some really cool screenshots
sales isn't going to do what you tell
them to do because you can make really
nice graphics in PowerPoint you have to
be able to work within those
organizations think like they think
stand up beside them when the times are
tough and they'll know that they can
trust you and they'll be willing to work
with you
good thanks one other thing I think I've
seen over again I've done it and maybe
much folks in the room here done your
first time out you're sitting with a
customer who's really tough and really
big and really important and demands
that you commit to the feature they need
right okay I never did and and the sales
rep looks over at you and the customer
looks over at you and your plane doesn't
leave four more hours to go back to
headquarters and you know out of your
mouth comes the the blurted sentences we
can get that to you by q2 which
engineering didn't commit to like you
just committed you know you're broken
rule number one which is you made a
commitment without the organization
behind you and I think that's that's a
sort of symptomatic of not having a long
enough view horizon and so if you're at
this company for any length of time
you're going to be sitting with that
customer next quarter and next year and
two years from now and the thing they
really need from you more than anything
else is for you to be you know an honest
broker here and to say I'll go back I'll
work hard I'll try to get that for you
but when we sit down against next
quarter or at the user group meeting
right you will know that that I speak
for the organization because I've got a
long-term view that I'm the honest
program the honorable person here who
you know I made far a little bit but I
won't lie and I think the it's really
hard as a product manager to go out in
the field and not say the thing the
customer wants you to say especially if
it's not true and then to go back of
course and deny that you said it right
Rita do you have an example of a mistake
you made that you learn the most from
yes you know there's a we've been
talking a lot of that or we talked a lot
about the difference between inbound and
outbound and you know in a natural
timeframe within an organization there
is a different emphasis on inbound
versus outbound and one of the earlier
mistakes that I made was not recognizing
when the pendulum was swinging to more
outbound or to more inbound and outbound
and if you happen to like something more
than one or the if you like if you like
me that likes the outbound piece much
more than the inbound piece if you don't
recognize that the pendulum is swinging
to inbound that there's you know the
organisation is suddenly switching to
being much more focused internally and
the relationship that that product
management has with say engineering then
you can really start people start to
think that you're not cooperating in
that sort of thing and to me that was I
learned that all too painfully that you
do have to recognize that sometimes
there are there is greater emphasis on
one than the other and that you have to
be able to shift what about you Tiffany
um I've made many I think one of the
ones that sticks out the the most in my
mind is and maybe this is a common theme
of some of the mistakes that I've made
in general is not trusting my instincts
and you know whether that's from a
product perspective getting pushed
either by development to do things the
way that development wants instead of
really standing up for the customer and
saying no this is will make much more
sense from what the customer is looking
for at the end of the day it's the
customers who have to use those products
and I guess it's the flip side of what
rich said which when you're in front of
the engineers and you're making
trade-offs and negotiations it's easy to
get sucked into the well this is the
easier way to do things
and I really regretted it later as we
started to get into the phases where we
had to go show customers well here's
what we're building and you kind of see
the look on their faces and you start to
shrink upon so in trust your instincts
as far as knowing what the customers
want and what's the best thing for them
I think dave has one - yeah I mean
adding adding to this theme that we've
talked about is I think a big lesson for
me that took me years is to realize that
products don't matter it's they're a
means to an end node and every time that
I've seen people you know I've got at
her product man oh god we've got the
stitcher and it just kicks butt on our
competitors feature right you know they
can't do this and the fact is that when
customers are buying and again you've
probably heard this
don't confuse selling with
implementation okay I mean customers
this is not true across all markets but
they don't always know exactly what it
is they want it's surprising sometimes
they get an RFP from some you know
industry analysts who in fact may not
really understand the market that
they're reviewing and you know do you
have one of these and do you have one of
these and you get caught up in you know
when customers are buying products to
them red and orange are the same color
okay they are not willing to invest at
the level of knowledge that you have
understanding your products in the
market you need to do this great job of
understanding but then you can't fool
yourself into thinking that anyone that
you're selling to has gone for the same
exercise or understands unique value
proposition a huge lesson is when we
what I realize and now I have luck we've
been able to teach us lesson to others
that sometimes you put things in your
product not because they're good for the
product
but because they're good for the sales
process because ultimately if you
believe that your solution will truly
solve the customers problem once they
acquire it our job is to make sure they
do acquire it I have been associated
with companies who produce tremendously
good products and failed so learning
what product were really producing is I
think the key lesson that I had to learn
over years and it's not the product it's
the successful result in both selling
and implementation rich and Dave what
would you have done differently in your
career looking back now that might help
members of the audience go ahead I'm
sorry this one's easy the first thing I
would have done is in 93 I would have
taken the job at Netscape
the second thing I would have done is in
96 I wouldn't have started my own
company I would have taken the job at
the EA it's it's a very hard question to
answer kind of you know revisionist
history I've made a lot of mistakes I
think that that's okay if I ever work
for a manager who thinks mistakes are
bad then for me I think I'm working for
the wrong executive because you know
marketing and everything we do in
high-tech it there's there's formula to
marketing there's a certain set of
things that I think it's very formulaic
but the implementation of that formula
is very unique and you have to
experiment and try so you know the thing
that I learned and I wish I would have
learned sooner is to feel okay making
mistakes to acknowledge making mistakes
one piece of advice I got from an old HP
manager is and it took me a little while
to fully internalize it um it's okay to
make mistakes you have to learn to
correct them quickly to acknowledge them
incorrectly quickly if you are if you
make mistakes and you try to perpetuate
them not to expose yourself you really
toast
sure so true actually yeah absolutely
one of the hardest lessons to learn is
to say yes I'm wrong but if it's a lot
and wanna try not do it again a couple
things come to mind for me I've been on
a few products that were cancelled
before their time you know so you're the
product manager on a product or a
project that's it's just not happening
and whether it's not a great product or
the politics or whatever if you ever
been on something for a year or a year
or two or three and you've had it
cancelled that's that's an emotional
loss right that's that's a member of
your family that's something you put
your heart and soul into you need to
give yourself a little time to
acknowledge that but it's not
necessarily a reason to walk out of the
company that you work at right so on the
one hand you know we throw ourselves
emotionally into the thing we do every
day you know we try to nurture and push
along our products sometimes they don't
work and it's really important I think
to separate out I'm angry and hurt
because they correctly cancelled the
product which ain't gonna sell or I'm
angry and hurt because they cancelled a
great product and I hate my management
and it's time to walk out the door and
those may feel the same but the results
are different so you know you bring your
heart into work every day but what you
need to well what would what rich is
saying you know when I see a product
manager who says you know this dog ain't
gonna hunt right I'm usually pretty
impressed even if they're wrong right
you've really got to be able to as a
product manager look at that product and
say I've invested the last six months
and you know what the market isn't there
or addition we can't be successful
against the competition right
that's a huge value it's right because
because I think as you'd said you know
when you're talking to customers in the
sales force everything about your
product is wonderful right it is the
greatest thing since you know you choose
it sliced bread but in your heart you
need to know how much of that's true and
maybe you don't tell anybody else but
the folks in park management but you
better know and you better be right
because when it's all over you need to
have done right thing
Dave and Rita what advice would you give
someone just starting out in product
management in order to be successful
Chuck wanted my advice to them as and
I've said this to you knows three words
network network network because you're
going to need help and you're going to
need advice and so really start to build
your network early on in your career and
I think that's really important and also
understand when you know within your own
organization don't be afraid to go to
your manager and say you don't know what
you're doing because that's what they're
there for they are there to help you so
I you know don't those are two things
that I think are important and then the
other thing as Dave Dave said is don't
be afraid to say that you made a mistake
I think that is so important
because you can move on people will
people at people admire honesty believe
it or not and so you don't
if us against the vsms huh so um what
would I add to that ultimately many of
you may want to be V PS of marketing
whether product management product
marketing or overall marketing I would
say that you know to do that you have to
have walked a mile and in a lot of
different roles but to be successful I
think you have to get pretty skilled at
any particular role at a given role you
have to learn how to do a product
managers job well or a product marketing
persons job well or to deal with the
analysts well and when you build it up I
think you can be a very good generalist
but I don't think you can be a general
it's just because he does survey you
know you've done one job and kind of
surveyed everything the other you know
piece of advice that I'd give and I
think this is you know controversial and
a lot of people in my peers may say you
know it's not necessary but I think you
need to learn how to sell I think if you
can walk a mile literally in the shoes
of a salesperson if you haven't had to
go through the process of convincing
someone to buy you know your product you
think it's easy I mean this is one of
the beauties of being you know sitting
home and watching the Superbowl right oh
my god I can't believe it made that call
it's really one of the things I've
learned over the years because every
function so it was surprise me every
function the company is really hard
really hard to be a good salesperson
it's really hard to be a good engineer
it's really hard to be a good product
manager and our word product goes
through sales and if you don't
understand why they're coming to you and
asking for the slide dujour that's a
symptom of something right until you've
been in a troll' understanding they
don't get it you haven't made it easy
for them to describe the value to the
customer so they're looking to patch
holes and symptoms and talk about
features and they're all over the place
so um I think any way that you can learn
through mentorship or through practice
to really understand the sales role you
will be a superior product manager and I
have a lot of respect anyone here from
you know currently or formerly from
Siebel I have a tremendous amount of
respect for the organization that
they've schmeyer put in place and for
how he effected marketing because that
was a group of people who understood
what the result was and it was revenue I
think there are some mistakes made in
beginning to believe and not continually
assuming something which is that my
differentiation if it is differentiation
it's no longer valid
I mean people hang their hat on what
they have done and say gosh were the
best you know we've got this unique
patented technology differentiates for
our competition believe me the minute
you have that in the market is being
eroded by press releases by other sales
people saying oh we're producing that so
you have to continually refresh and
continually stay ahead of the market but
I think the Siebel organization really
was an organization and still is an
organization that puts the customer out
there and the salesperson out there
rich and Tiffany for those who are
already a product manager maybe in the
middle of their careers what advice can
you give them about preparing to move up
okay I'll go first so I just come back
some of the Rita had said about
networking networking networking
[Music]
some of the groups in your company never
get talked to and feel really lonely and
know lots of really cool stuff I'm
thinking of people like the customer
support organization and the QA team
right nobody ever talks to them and
they're off in a corner and they're
really lonely and some of them are
really good and smart some of the best
help I've ever gotten you know has been
from peers and organizations that are
usually ignored and you know not just
you know the sales of course is out
there but you know that there are people
out there trying to do their hardest
every day and they don't really know
where they fit and if you can help them
fit into the process and understand
where where their work is valuable and
also learn from them I think you've
built both skills and a network that are
the things that move you up
[Music]
I think I'm also going to touch on
something Rita said earlier I think
making the move from an individual
product manager or product marketer to
that first level of management is
actually a lot harder than making the
move from there to being a group product
manager and their to being a VP of
product marketing or product management
and letting go is something that is
absolutely important and I am a die-hard
product manager I live in you know lived
and breathed the details of who my
customers were and how they were using
the product and what was in the product
it's incredibly hard to let that go and
I think one of the things that you can
do to be the most successful in letting
go and doing that is listen to the
questions that the people that you
respect ask you listen to what your VP
of Sales or your best salesperson asks
you when you go through a pitch with
them listen to the hard questions that a
really good engineer asks you when
you're trying to convince them of a
certain set of things that you want to
do and the product listen to what the
executive team asks you when you go give
a launch presentation or you go give a
product presentation or a competitive
review listen to the things that they
ask you and those are the questions that
you want to start asking of yourself and
asking of your team and what you'll
start finding is that you can actually
get the information that you need to be
comfortable that you can go to your job
that you can lead your team without
having to understand every bit and byte
of information yourself it's something
that I still struggle with to this day
that I have to remind myself constantly
of and as a part of that it's really
about using your people
reowww said which I thought is
incredibly important is that you don't
have to have all the answers yourself
and I think that's another just kind of
inherent trait that a lot of us have
because of who we are that you feel that
you want to have the answers yourself
use your people get them involved if you
can learn how to make them successful
they will make you successful and that
will carry with you no matter how many
people you have working underneath you
great in just a minute we're going to
have Katherine come up to talk about
what she looks for when she's recruiting
for candidates I just like that's Dave
and Rita what they look for when they're
interviewing people to work on their
teens
[Music]
and since I've just gone through this
with Kathy she can correct me anyway
what I look for for in terms of product
product management product marketing as
I look there's some personal
characteristics that I think are
important and they can be as equally as
important as what I would call job
experience so on the job experience side
I look for somebody that has and
obviously it depends on what where your
organization is in terms of maturity and
that sort of thing but I look for
somebody it has some sort of product
lifecycle knowledge experience in terms
of the process around how do you get
from you know the distillation of what
that product is all the way through to
launch they have to understand what that
process is and so certainly I look for
that I look for domain expertise that
may mean domain expertise in a
particular area so you know if I'm
working in financial systems and I'm
looking for a product manager then
ideally what I want is somebody that has
a financial systems background or an
enterprise systems background I think
you look for on the personal side you
look for people that have they have a
sense of confidence they're sitting in
front of you not fidgeting doing all
that sort of stuff you know but somebody
that has confidence because it's so
important for product manager to have a
presence when they are talking to
whether it be engineering whether it be
sales they have to be credible there is
no way that you can you won't be
successful if you are not and then I
look for that inherent quality clear
communication also important but I also
look for energy and passion I don't want
somebody that is just going to sit back
and just write up MRD I want somebody
that is clearly energetic and passionate
about the field that they're in
agree with all of that obvious additions
you know common theme from a
customer-focused right
they don't think and talk in those terms
you know they're probably the wrong
person for my my organization I think
the key thing that I look for is
judgment I always try to hire experience
but you know the world that we live in
isn't a set of spreadsheets in which you
can calculate the right answer
I wish it were I mean it would make my
job a lot easier so what's really
interesting is that with all the market
essentially do with all the customer
analysis you do with is just tremendous
amount of facts for me the difference
between the great product marketing and
management people I have worked for and
then not so great is their ability to
into it is for their ability to
integrate under the curve all these
complex things and when I see that
judgment when I see that they're able to
assess all this stuff and kind of put it
together then I think I found someone
who's probably right for my organization
one more question for the panelists and
then we'll open it up to questions after
Kathy gives her take on what she looks
for one thing guys just one thing what's
your key to your success center with
rich one major thing there was a big
assumption wasn't there
you seem to have been successful what's
the key to your success you know you
work hard you throw your heart into it
every day pass I know I have to go back
I'm an excellent listener and I think
that has really stood me in great stead
I think passion great and Dave you know
success has defined and being successful
as a marketer or being successful in a
career which I think of two different
things
so I'll take a different point of view
from being successful in marketer to be
successful in a career I think don't
stay in any one place too long I've seen
people who you know there's this thing I
call the kind of father-son syndrome you
grow up and you get to a point and your
dad's looking for advice and he doesn't
look to you because he sees you as a
thirteen year old or a twelve year old
or an eight year old and it takes like
10 more years but in in your work
relationships you're learning so the day
you come in you're learning often sets
the framework for how people see you
three years from now even though you are
a new person and so you know at every
now and again you need to have a fresh
perspective you need to Loveridge it's
like buying houses you know you get
certain value then you buy a bigger
house because you've got equity in that
and and you you know you Loveridge that
and so in terms of your career if you
stay stagnant you stay in one place too
long
you will probably lose a lot of the
value that you've created great answers
okay now we'll have
can come up to tell you her perspective
on getting a job in product management
so I think we have the expert sitting
next to me and so in putting together my
answer I'm actually using a lot of what
I heard tonight it I actually put it
together beforehand but a lot of it is
common so I'm going to use some of the
words we work today first of all as an
executive recruiter looking for product
marketing management positions it's sort
of a given that they've got the product
marketing product management skills if
they don't have that I don't need to
waste the time talking to that so I look
for the personal characteristics and we
heard them tonight number one is
customer focus when I'm asking you about
how did you come up with the product or
messaging I need to hear I went out and
talked to customers I gathered the
requirements by talking to customers I
met with the analysts and learned this I
met with my salespeople and learn this
it's all about knowing the market the
customers I mean we couldn't have heard
this more lively than about the pan was
brought up tonight second around that
I'm Damon I since I worked in product
marketing at Siebel it's the sales focus
and now pound you better know how to
sell product marketing is out there
sharing the the confidence in the
product and where the product direction
is going so you need to be credible as a
salesperson having the confidence around
the product line around and other
personal characteristic I'll just call
it team it's the team management
it's the credibility that we talked
about being able to rally that
cross-functional team that you have no
control over managing having the product
management skills to manage that team so
a lot of those kind of personal
characteristics and the last part is
that I look for then is the experience
the job experience and as I've been
working on searches over the last year
people on that last year every time I
look at it people hire me to do the
difficult searches so they're not
looking just for product marketing
product management but it gets into deep
experience around some sort of
technology or some sort of industry
focus so around technology
was in tax with David I needed industry
fifa he's been a customer too so I
needed people with them experience in a
credit card processing back-office
now mortgage industry and it was very
very specific within financial services
other things like on technology business
activity monitoring apartment within
business analytics or the marriage of
employee performance with Business
Analytics so you can see how I'm
splitting hairs on very specifics and
then sometimes they throw in the
technology plus the industry experience
right now I need small and medium
business focused people in enterprise
software so you end up getting a lot of
different combinations as I'm looking
for it so I think that it comes back to
the personal characteristics and the job
experience now it's time to turn this
over to all of you so you can ask
questions to our panelists so one of the
craziest thing is people asking for ten
years of experience in technology is
only been out for two isn't that kind of
a are you looking for more for those
personal characteristics and then
actually the technical or business very
sure I mean I remember when Java was
only out two years and you know like you
wanted somebody with ten years of Java
but it didn't exist
I think the often the common theme is
tell me why the things you've done line
up with the things I need so you know we
call the middleware for a while and we
call the plumbing for a while and then
we called it you know connectivity for a
while but it's all the same junk
metal right so you've got to make the
case why you really do understand the
things they need even if you know you
learn code before C++ have the pluses on
of anyone else other questions
right back there you guys talked a
little bit about being important to have
a sales set of skills to understand what
they're driving how much do you think
it's important to share the engineers
skill set and how much of the product
you think you need to be able to make
yourself in order to sign up better from
an engineer and a non engineer on this
one
yeah yeah okay so I were an engineer Oh
whenever you join a group or a new
company there's a first meeting with
some of the engineers where they're
going to ask you a couple of what they
think are softball technical questions
right and if you get them wrong you are
forever written off as just another
stupid MBA with Italian who doesn't know
anything so in my view you need to have
enough to appreciate what they do you
need to have a feel for the technology
you don't have to be as good as they are
and they don't want you to but if you're
really a lightweight they know it so if
you don't have an engineering background
how do you get the credibility with
engineering or well I think you need to
study up and you need to speak enough of
their language you don't have to be an
engineer but you have to be enough
engineering ish that you know the
antibodies don't trigger yeah I'm a non
engineer and one of the first things
that I did when I was in technology was
I used to attach myself to an engineer
and learned as much as I could right
away and that stood me instead my good
stead thought on my entire life because
I learned enough in terms of what I
needed to know and I just kept doing
that I would always attached not
attachment I will always find out what I
would need to know in order to be again
be credible so but if your question is
can is is your question whether
engineering gives you a stronger have
stronger leg up to be a good product
manager yeah I suppose mad word for word
is broken into Internet company arts
background and if this is about getting
to the top how much it how much that
back am I gonna meet
or up by yes generally they're going to
be deficiencies that I'm going to run
into things like that I personally don't
think there would be deficiencies as
long as you start to gain enough
knowledge that again that you're
credible I mean I don't I don't I don't
have an engineering background and
certainly I that's what I did initially
when I started out in the software
industry is really I you know I went I
basically attached myself to somebody
that I could learn from and I think you
do that I think you get successful I
think those I put my
president reality is about 10 years ago
[Music]
and people that I mix really know what's
my other people brother books who stayed
up with it the fact they've got these in
that condition that that Senate helps me
out in credibility but it's kind of a
little joke to myself and so I think
that if you can't speak the acronyms and
read up on stuff just let yourself
you're probably better off than I am
there's another element which is it's
how you're doing your product management
so if you think product management is
about solving the technical problem then
you're probably doing it wrong and you
do need to know the engineering if
you're very good at helping the
engineers understand what the problem is
you show them the respect and help them
figure out how to solve the problem not
trying to be an engineer but helping
them in this huge bridging process
between a problem and you that's where
you have the credibility and then you
know and really show them respect
because they're doing something harder
just how to solve the problem then I
think you get a lot of credibility and
the other side of that is I think part
of our job as product managers is to
change the frame of reference for the
engineers so it's not about engineering
right and like I've got a great
engineering team at my company I love
them because they constantly hammer be
about the messages but what we're
communicating with the customers and we
really understand and how much money are
we making and what if this analysts say
they really really care about whether
their product is seeing the light of day
and being successful when I was with HP
I was you know in the engineering group
I was in an engine
a management role in what made my group
different than all the other engineering
teams in this division is we posted and
track our revenue and they loved it when
their product was being sold and they
wanted to go talk to the customers
rather than buy the product what we do
different and it completely changed
their frame of reference to like as an
engineer I'm yet to meet an engineer who
wants to produce a product that no one
wants or who wants to produce a product
that's going to get shelved so I think
if you can bring them into the world of
success you know they're not going to
care whether you actually know the
difference between XML and then I'll
throw on the blank there's another
question down here okay okay how about
here
that that products are successful and
and the need for engineering is not to
suppose so Ed Colligan did Paul just
recently made a statement which which
rang true for me in my career and it was
that if we just execute to plan and
follow the road map that we created we
will be tremendously successful as a
company and our high tech company this
is there's a there's a good bad I'd like
to hear your comments about that about
killing our people's creativity high
when the situation requires executing
much more than an event did everybody
hear the question how do you keep
creativity high when execution is
important
well I think you're always in a
situation where you're creating it I
think some of this depends on where our
company is and it's given life cycles
but I think there's always a sense of
creativity and creation that goes into
your roadmap no matter whether you're
capable of building a 12-month roadmap
and sticking to it although I've never
seen that and so I think within that you
can keep people interested and excited
with it all goes back to the customer
again and you're building that product
to solve a problem and that's the
exciting part and no matter how
disciplined you are or how long it takes
you to build that or even if you're not
constantly iterating your products and
adding new features the excitement comes
from seeing the faces of your customers
light up when you've solved a problem
for them and from an engineering
perspective I have to agree with Dave
there's nothing that gets them more
excited than when they see that their
product is going to make a difference
for a customer and nothing gets sales
more excited in that as well and that's
how you keep everybody engaged in that
process even if you're more in an
execution type of mode and I'd say I've
never been lucky enough to work on a
product that was so good that it
actually met all of the customers needs
there's almost always a tremendous
amount left to do and there's always
more to do than you can get done and the
engineering team can't get done and you
know may sound good but I've yet to run
into that product that really is so good
and when I was at PeopleSoft and I was
headed up the product strategy
organization for financials I mean by
the time I took that on I mean that that
product had been out there for a long
time and it was you know they're little
still there's tons of stuff that you can
do from a creativity point of view to
and that's when you become so customer
focused in terms of what's what can you
do that's going to really get them
excited and there's still lots of things
that you can do that gifts I'm really
excited now I think one of the
interesting things along those lines
that Siebel did a good job of was even
after they had brought to market a
tremendous amount of functionality one
of the things they turn to was how do we
make the deployment experience better
for customers so it's not even always
about the features in and of itself it's
really looking at the whole ecosystem
around your products and how do you
continue to involve some of those things
which can be equally as exciting I see a
Business School case being written about
this how about a question out here
go ahead fall see more and more
you want to be in product marketing or
product management just starting out how
does how do you deal with that because
otherwise you don't get just get your
foot in basically you don't have me
davin I don't think you need an MBA to
be in product management however in a
climate where there may be lots of
applicants it's certainly an easy thing
to ask for the thing I think is really
valuable though about having done one is
you get a good breadth of experience you
know you've done the American Airlines
case and you think you know something
about Airlines you studied a lot of
stuff and I think it's a good broadening
so that you're you're thinking about
more corners of the problem could you've
learned it anyplace else sure you know I
did toilets for a second here and I'd
say I'd love to hire an MBA for our
product management side of mind but I
never hire one who's just graduated
because they need about two years for
their head to come back to normal sides
but
but there's some other paths so you know
when I was working with Cathy on these
hires I was faced with a really really
tough problem which is how do I find a
experienced product manager who really
understands vertical domain because
first finding good product managers is
hard finding domain experts is hard so
one of the paths and it's you know it's
not a direct path but it's if you can
gain that domain expertise if you have
that customer understanding maybe it's
through a consulting role maybe if
you're an engineer the next role is a
pre-sales
engineer so that you're applying your
technical skills into the selling
process you gain that domain expertise
and now you're in a position to say I
really understand this problem and I
understand engineering and maybe I don't
have an MBA but how many MBAs actually
understand the problem we're solving so
I think that customer experience set in
some way shape or form can be a
tremendous bridge into product
management I don't think there's like
they've said there's multiple paths that
you can take to get there
and if you look at the customer being
the center there's a lot of different
functions that touch the customer and if
you can get that kind of experience and
then look to the product marketing
organization to start to learn the
process or how to do things use those
types of people as a mentor and I don't
have an MBA and the path that I took was
through customer programs into beta
program management which was a piece of
the product marketing product management
organized
and then extended into the product
marketing organization from there and
you know I've managed to take that on
the road um back there in the white
sweater yeah what are the questions
[Music]
to
yo and what challenge
have that experience working with the
team and engineering team and someplace
you know China wherever what challenges
what were the big greatest challenges
how did you over overcome
so I've done India and Costa Rica and
then little little bits of Europe in
Russia
this is bigger than just a product
management issue this is a whole company
issue so you have to make some really
hardcore decisions at one company we had
the first level the engineering design
team locally so it was a very small team
and we work to refine the product
requirements to the you know initial
design so that what was being then
transitioned between this team and the
offshore organization with highly
refined it was about execution at that
point in time so a lot of it depends on
where the cut line is going to be
between you know the market requirement
and implementation actually there's a
there's a great chart the Harvard
Business View Business Review actually
put out on how you decide what you're
going to outsource versus what you're
not going to outsource and there's some
key differentiating to outsource things
that are that are brand new usually
going outsource things that in fact
would have been existence for a while so
there's a lot of risk what you have to
really do is look at it from a risk
point of Yoona's de said it's really a
company-wide decision this isn't just
product management and how you manage it
is very different and what we've said is
absolutely true I've not been associated
with a let's just go dump everything
offshore we start with QA and support
and so that you get to know the product
then goes maintenance engineering to
make sure that the products are
maintained and they learn base the
products and is typically an evolution
even if it's an accelerated pace but
it's an evolution because availing of
that core competency it's not just about
someone coding I mean
again like marketing engineering is not
that simple we have time for one more
question but I think some of the
speakers might hear stick them right
back here okay a customer site that's
never happened you have luxury to say to
us question is what is I mean I'm sure
there's no perfect solution but what is
the strategy to balance the priority is
between things that are pulling image it
deems to be close video recorder versus
a strategic thing going on which is
going on for like the next two quarters
and how do you manage data in your
engineering team of one track getting
that money very briefly answer both
questions separately I don't know if any
of you spend time Japan but the Japanese
have a hundred ways of not saying no but
saying no and you know that feature
would be very difficult to implement and
I really need to go check and see how
many resources going to take there's a
hundred ways to signal to the customer
that you check very very very seriously
but they didn't get yes out of your
mouth um I think the broader question is
you know how do you prioritize the short
and long term I think your answer is is
exactly right I will there's a book that
I read years ago I was in a bookstore it
was like a secondhand kind of bookstore
I saw this thing and Akamai the title
and just you know being politically
correct I can't describe it the first
word in the title and my son would say
was the mother of all swear words okay
and the second word was yes okay so you
put those two
and the entire book and it's the most
bizarre book you'll ever read was that
yes is always an acceptable answer so
one of the things that I think a product
manager has to learn is to say
absolutely we can do that there is
nothing worse than being with a sales
guy and saying no no is never an
acceptable answer for a product manager
yes is always the right answer learn
that one and you will be successful yes
does not mean yes we will do this thank
you - yes means absolutely we can do
this for you let's talk about that okay
are you prepared to sign the purchase
order if you're prepared to sign that
purchase order I think we can find a way
to get it done I mean there's a hundred
ways I'm not saying that's always the
right answer but yes is always the right
answer you have to learn how to say yes
right way if you're gonna be successful
in this role and and often the yes is
yes let's spend a couple minutes on the
whiteboard figuring out exactly why you
need this thing and I might just happen
to have in my pocket the feature we
actually did that solves your problem
thirty Seconds I'll close that thing I
think this short long term is really
hard trade-off and you better be
thinking with the team about whether you
have enough revenue to get to the long
term and whether the one customer you're
talking about is big enough to really
float your company or you've left all
your other customers on the side of the
road and you've traded off this quarter
for you know death next
you gotta run the numbers in the
salespeople know the answer so thank you
too